ليس سرا رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه مارك ميلي في اسرائيل لبحث
التنسيق لصد التهديدات التي تشكلها ايران
على حد تعبير بيان للبنتاجون زياره تاتي
على واقع تطورات في الملف النووي الايراني
بعد ان تحدث تقرير للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه عن جزيئات يورانيوم مخصبه بنسبه
تجاوزت ثلاثه وثمانين في المئه خلال
زيارته التقى نظيره الاسرائيلي وفي اجندته
كذلك لقاءات مع وزير الدفاع
ورئيس جهاز المساد دافيد بارنيا
زياره تستبق وصول وزير الدفاع الامريكي
الى اسرائيل الاسبوع المقبل وتاتي في جو
محتقن داخليا واقليميا بعد تقرير الوكاله
الدوليه عن اقتراب ايران من بلوغ العتبه
النوويه وهو السقف الذي وضعته تل ابيب
لنفسها قبل قرار توجيه ضربه للمفاعلات
النوويه الايرانيه يضاف الى هذا ما نقلته
هيئه البث الاسرائيلي عن مصادر امريكيه
واسرائيليه بشان سعي طهران لنيل منظومه
صواريخ اس 400 الروسيه وان ذلك قد يحفز
اسرائيل لتقريب موعد اتخاذ قرار قصف
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه
وهذه نقطه خلاف امريكي اسرائيلي اخرى فهو
شنط حسب تصريحاتها الرسميه ورغم تعطل
مساعي اعاده ايران للالتزام بالاتفاق
النووي ما تزال تشدد على اولويه
الدبلوماسيه كاستراتيجيه المعتمده للتعامل
مع ايران فيما تبدي اسرائيل تشكيكا مستمرا
في هذا النهج وتؤكد ان توجيه ضربه لبرنامج
ايران النووي هو الحل الوحيد الكفيل بوضع
حد لما تقول انه طموحات طهران النوويه اما
اداره بايدن فتبقي سياسه الضغوط القصوى
التي ورثتها عن اداره ترامب مفعله وتقول
ان العقوبات واخرها ما اعلنته الخزانه
الامريكيه الخميس عن فرض عقوبات على شركات
شحن ايرانيه كفيله باعاده طهران الى
الاتفاق النووي لكن حسابات الزمن
الانتخابي الامريكي قد تجعل هذا الهدف
مؤجلا في وقت ترى فيه اسرائيل ان الزمن
يمضي بطيئا في الولايات المتحده وسريعا في
ايران المتهمه اسرائيليا
بالسعي لتطوير سلاح النووي وتتسع نقاط
الخلاف بين واشنطن وتل ابيب لتشمل التصعيد
الاسرائيليه تجاه الفلسطينيين حيث تصل
درجه التنديد الامريكي بالتصريحات
والسياسه الاسرائيليه الى مستويات غير
مسبوقه وسط امتعاد امريكي واضح من العناصر
اليمنيه المتطرفه في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
وسياساتها التحريضيه تجاه الفلسطينيين